Please tell us about your ideas of the problem of gender integrated combat units
and how it affects morale.
Please talk about the rule trans people should or should not serve in combat
units.
Huh.
Well,
you know,
I wouldn't say that
exactly an expert in that regard.
Um,
I don't know how gender
power,
multiple gendered combat units are going to work.
My,
because I'm fundamentally a traditionalist in most ways,
mostly because I'm afraid of the unintended consequences of radical change.
I would say that it's dangerous to adjust a system that's working and it's very
hard for me to imagine a situation,
especially in a combat situation where the women and men can actually be treated
equally.
I don't think that the broader society would even want to see that.
I mean,
I suppose there are exceptions to that sort of thing,
like,
um,
the situation perhaps in Israel,
although I suspect even in Israel that the women take the more,
the less combat heavy jobs.
No,
I don't know that,
but maybe I'm just being prejudiced in that answer,
but
it just doesn't seem to me to be a very wise idea.
Um,
what role trans people should serve.
I really can't say.
I don't have anything,
any advice about that.
I'm just not
informed enough to make,
uh,
a conclusion about that.
I think it's very strange.
However,
I've talked to some people in the Canadian armed forces and in recent months,
and I do think it's very strange that this is the sort of problem that our
military is actually trying to solve for.
You think that there would be more important things to concentrate on them?
Rapid Gender,
um,
equalization in the military.
I just don't see why that's such a priority,
but maybe that's just my old fashioned conservatism speaking.
It could be,
it could be that right.